hidey-ho reject oh and nation no I'm
Greg elbow Jonny room told me your name
I'm John Oh Romo John Romo is here today
the first guest of the month
the hottest girl I could find bring on
the real rejects came in the form of a
thirteen-year-old boy that's right
he's 13 ladies and I'm Korean massages
yeah Johnny ax is known for a while I've
been wanting to bring him on the channel
then I met Collider which is a thriving
company and he went on my brother's
channel and I said you must come on mine
Johnny have you seen the channel my
raccoon mighty raccoon yeah no well
we're gonna watch compilation really
awesome videos this one is baby Yoda
makes baby Groot Andrew Gordon my friend
got me this shirt thank you Andrew
Johnny what am i plugging for you you
have like a channel music I do I have a
channel it's do I give to your boys say
the name of the channel's name is
Jonathan Rome there's no do you have a
unique URL I do but it's like it's like
from what my channel was called in 2013
which is a little embarrassing the
youtube.com slash user slash total geek
Lord
back when I thought I like Star will
stop stop chatting
[Music]
[Music]
get him get him
that's like holy a whole animated yeah
oh do not f with the baby Yoda oh no
we're gonna eat it baby it looks
incredible Panasonic
oh I don't love to watch these two match
up I mean baby okay easily oh yeah just
some verses or meets
[Music]
Oh me mad Oh
Vin Diesel know they're gonna kiss ya
[Laughter]
like little hairs on the thing
there it is yeah I thought I was coming
oh no no don't hurt him make him love
you he's
like this
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
hell yeah yeah dance you two enjoy
yourselves
that's right that's not talking about
yeah yeah yeah yeah making up for the
lack of dialogue just feeling like I
honestly need to be smart are they
that's obviously there's gonna be a port
somewhere
[Music]
and these best royalty-free so many are
sketches because of Kevin McNeil yeah
mighty raccoon well done buddy go
subscribe his channel if you haven't
done so already well before we talk
about this video let's talk about it
[Music]
really quick what do you think of your
first mighty raccoon bTW there was a
cuteness and then there was cuteness and
they all just kind of came on the same
little playing field right there the
animation was cool baby Yoda's animated
like specifically the detail on baby
Yoda like the wrinkles and the
fingernails and like she like I notice
stuff yeah I thought there was a little
bit more attention to detail put towards
baby Yoda or maybe it's just not as
complex for something for baby I mean
dude still look great yeah it's probably
cuz Groot needed all the like little
wood edges there's a jumpsuit like yeah
it got me excited at the possibility
yeah you could do one of those like
Disney Plus animated series like like a
whatever yeah like a Marvel what is so
cool wait and then they can hi everybody
right good and it all just works up for
everyone I was watching it was going I
don't need them to talk these even say I
am Groot you said it once did he he did
we just said something we were just so
oh darn it the thing I said this is the
idea of those two you like sharing the
screen together it seems fathomable and
I wonder if I look a little weird
because baby Groot is CGI baby oh baby
Yoda is puppet obviously what they would
do if baby Yoda is going from this
universe to the Marvel Universe you
across this little wormhole that would
also make him CGI at the end of it ah
because you know it's that kind of
universe you have to have the CGI to
make the creature Sean Gunn's gonna do
the like character motion capture and
Bradley Cooper will get all the credit
it's possible to see it happening
consider another both like part of the
you know Star Wars galactic dougherty's
a galaxy galactic it's in the galaxy
down how crazy would it be if they
crossed those over in a desperate
attempt to stay it's a save the Star
Wars movies yeah I was so nervous
watching this cuz normally these are
reverses videos or some alternate fight
video that we're gonna watch so doesn't
get really violent the whole time I was
like oh no because I count hot dog
fighting so Jiraiya no don't don't don't
hurt each other please get along and I
forgot the name with it I forgot the
title of the videos I'm so used to watch
I can't remember who is my verses or
meet like wait
but hey mighty raccoon you guys killed
it I love the usage of when they of how
they use the camera it's a life you have
some of the the motion that's out to be
a little more real oh yeah the ship
zooming or ship focus and whatnot oh
well sorry the shift focus the paradigm
the way you use them to shine wide shot
yes I don't go to see son who does that
all boy I got a lauren street element
guys well if you haven't done so already
subscribed and Maddie racoon subscribe
to the real rejects you know what to do
people say it all the time click the
notification belt make sure you have way
too many notifications in your youtube
sanity we covered all the mandalorian
here on youtube so you can watch all
those reactions here have you seen the
mandalorian yeah I'm yeah it's it's good
it's really good it's really great no I
love it it's great it's no high school
musical the musical the series but it's
I'll leave I like to end this with a
page from the day shout out to a man
named Tyler hey our beautiful friend
from Wisconsin
he has such a charming cuddly
personality about himself he is like the
equivalent if you put baby Yoda and baby
Groot together you would get first you
and then like Tyler Hague so Tyler I
hate Tyler I want to own a
funkopop of you one day buddy I just
want to caress you and hold you have you
used the force on me that's consensual
you said that to me before I came in I
just thought I came
[Laughter]